boo leg calves here with the legendary
Scott Storch man who needs no
introduction your new single just came
out yes sir I don't want to [ __ ] up the
pronoun pronunciation juego del calor
which pretty much just means like hot
fire yeah yeah how fire why I'm curious
cuz I think ever since you announced
you're gonna be doing like a project
super excited to hear what you I know
you're sitting on some huge records yeah
you know we're not that far along the
product I've been in the project but we
I got like four or five solid songs and
I really want to use for the project
foot we're just getting going on it but
you know we wanted to you know put out a
single and and do something like the
first time that was like super global
and and you know had had potential to
hit many markets and just do something
tacky like white like like Scott Storch
don't we don't we don't necessarily
associate you with the Spanish [ __ ] come
on man you know about that daddy yankee
impact oh oh [ __ ] that's real yeah but I
just mean like I just mean like overall
like you don't have to say oh yeah you
know I mean I just for me pioneering and
just trying new stuff and even new stuff
for me is fun you know I mean it makes
it like I don't like getting burnt out
on doing like what you'd expect from me
so it still has that melody and
production value and you know I'm known
for and it's doing something that I feel
like I don't know hey listen you're one
of the most prolific producers of all
times I think you do whatever the [ __ ]
you want right now I want to go back
brokers like we were just having this
discussion about the roots and I'm like
a first time I ever saw the roots I was
probably 13 and this was like 2002 or
some [ __ ] okay and this was after you
would probably be stopped working with
him like on a more production but I
remember like buying the bootleg of
organics which was like the first roots
album but it wasn't like the first major
album no that was
you want more do you want more because
their official debut did organics we
recorded the whole album one day Wow
yeah I'm saying we've recorded the whole
album in one day was that out of
necessity because back then studio time
was expensive in it well yeah but then
at the same time yeah we wanted to you
know make it economical at a limited
budget but we're we're a live band we
were used to playing these songs live
and we were able to all set up at the
same time record to a click or a cowbell
or whatever we were recording right and
the band would start the song and we
would cut them off like they're from the
beginning then I'm curious wholly
different like back then like being
around that early 90s Philly hip hop
energy like especially the roots like
did you feel because at the time there
was no precedent for that much live
instrumentation in hip-hop or let alone
a band in hip-hop yeah what was did it
feel like specialized like now we
obviously the roots are you know one of
the greatest rap groups of all time back
then as a kid did you realize like what
you are a part of yeah no I mean I knew
we were on some special you know like
there was a couple of things that sort
of resembled what we were doing at that
time but it wasn't what we were doing
like I mean like the diggable plan it
yeah of course some things like what but
they were they were rapping over samples
there was another group in Philly called
the goats at the time but that was like
a college band but it was like hip-hop
like you know right the roots were
special you know I knew it was gonna
have a long lifespan but I just as much
as I loved being a part of it I wanted
so much more to be a record producer and
stay in the studio I'm the kind of
person that likes to like wake up in my
house every day and I'm not a big fan of
going on the road and just chose a
different life yeah so obviously you win
your first Grammy with the roots which
was I mean I love by the way
shots everybody watch your purses battle
Oh where's that [ __ ] was legendary it
was it was it was it got ugly as all
but like at what point in time after you
pivoted away from working with them
full-time like what was that that first
big look for Scott Storch as Scott
Storch - bran like as as a solo guy who
decided to break away from this roots
crew like what was that first thing that
happened where you're like oh [ __ ] like
I think this can actually work like I
like me as a record producer can
actually be a thing I went with this
dude the guy that actually got the
record deal for the roots Derrick
Jackson you know he brought it to Wendy
goldstein and etc etc but you know after
I left I ended up getting in contact
with this guy and he took me to New York
from Philly and we did a run all the way
around the city and went from labelled a
label that's that the other couple of
you know we all I was hoping that just
cut a record while I was in New York
like that's all I wanted right and sure
one guy came through for me a first
client who was it Busta Rhymes busting
and we made a song called blood ow okay
and we went on the strikes
huh it was an anarchy anarchy yeah an
RKO and then I set up a gig to come back
the following week and work with Capone
annoy Yaga CNN yeah and Capone the day
that I was going to the studio to meet
he literally was getting brought from
prison to the studio so this was like
his first steel stop after getting out
yeah did you end up on did you end up
havin production on more report or any
or what did you yeah that's crazy man so
Capone and Noriega it's crazy because
nori also had a lot to do with Pharrell
starting with super thug yeah that's and
it's kind of interesting to know to know
but but um obviously you're the you're
known as the piano man you know what I'm
saying like
do you once like you cuz I feel like
there's a Scott Storch sound and a lot
of people say that you know you like
like but when it comes to the keys and
and and the way you played and bro like
I in the early 2000s I just feel like
you had a signature sound yeah I mean I
think you still do but but yeah well you
know what like a lot of that sound it's
it's a part of the evolution of what
hip-hop became yeah and you know we have
to leave it there and go for new stuff
and innovate because you know people you
don't want people to be like oh that's
what he was doing back there like we
want some new [ __ ] you've done a great
job of pivoting recently um because I
feel like you kind of had to like kind
of prove to everybody like your your
back
over the last one I had to get back
because you know I left music to go off
and do the debauchery and [ __ ] that I I
did when I wasn't making music doing
drugs and all right and come back flash
forward a decade later and now you're
trying to like you know you have to
reevaluate where is music now and like
you know we learn it I mean not the
musicianship part but the production
Sonics and you know the way you know the
simplicity of things and you know like I
had to relearn it ya know I feel like
you you you you kind of did something
that's so hard to do because if you
think it super or if you do if you think
that a lot of the producers that were
popping back then like a lot of those
guys aren't around anymore there's a few
there's like Timbaland there's Dre
there's yourself but like the fact that
you're able to tap in with trippy red
yeah and tap in with we used to have a
specific way of looking at music as a
whole lesson you know producer musician
and once you think you know the right
way to make done because there is no
right you're not women it was all right
way to make music it's always evolving
and changing so you have to like
constantly reinvent yourself and if
you're stuck it's subjective you
subjective yeah the people that can just
keep going and and evolving it that's
you know that's the things we're um
in I always wanted to ask you this I
remember you did clap back for John role
right which was a fire ants record but
at that time nobody was [ __ ] John
roll this guy to that weird part of his
career where 50 they had the beef and
people kind of chose science when you
ended up working with 50 on the massacre
did was that like a conversation like
like you did lean back obviously yeah I
was 50 seen my kind of guy and I know
you made that clear to everybody I am
NOT on some rat beef [ __ ] but at the
time he was and I'm trying to eat like I
was a starving or you know you could
have mad records I still haven't made no
money so my focus was working and like
you know I'll leave those beefs to other
people
but like a lot of times I would find
myself doing records you know for people
and like I would get like that clap back
is an example like it wasn't supposed to
go to him like that
that bee was so fine that beat I made in
my house the day before I was going to
New York I was going to New York to work
with with um Janet Jackson and white
left studio I remember just clear as a
bell and that day before PD crack and
beanie sigel
steak knives in my house in Florida I
made that beat and I guess um you know
just it never happened like they just
were asleep in the studio wasn't you
know whatever so that was meant first I
left the next day to New York and I got
the call from like yo I need something I
was like I giving this beat and it was
like a two track and never got that song
never got mixed Wow
yeah like the music of it was just given
like a two track on like a dad tape like
from the crib so I remember they'd
eacute it or whatever that's crazy
weird how like records and though that
it's funny because I think that's when
it like obviously it wasn't like the
biggest hit in the world
he was so hard man it could I used to
cringe in the club when I would hear it
because it was like oh my god it sounds
so thin compared to all if you knew it
was it mastered yeah it wasn't mixed my
master I'm like Jude making me look bad
yo so another you know when we watched
the battle
chance everybody who watched the vs.
battle which you and Manny fresh the dr.
Dre records I think are kind of like had
to be like one of like the turning
crowning moments of your career like
talk about like obviously being a part
of chronic 2001 which was very very
interesting time in hip hop cuz I
remember that album being teased for so
long and I remember death row
cock-blocking and putting out an album
called allicin yeah and who doesn't
write cuz it came out and like I
remember I was like tooth like that
didn't make sense but I remember that
weird ass death row album it had like a
cigar yeah had the cigar on the cover
and then the guy who sounded just like
Snoop Dogg there was a guy on that album
that was like a snoop impersonator I
swear to God
sure was petty but nonetheless liked
that album was it's one of the top 10
greatest hip hop albums of all time
can you talk about like how did that
initial connection happen with Dre I
think you've spoken a lot about like the
process of making those records but like
you getting into the fold with Dre
becoming a part of that team that worked
on that project okay so there was
obviously the moment where I left the
roots and I was trying to make a career
for myself what year did you officially
like breakaway in 95 okay yeah I left
the group I actually ended up in 97
getting a visit from them when I was in
the middle of working on a song but
that's all other story and I gave them
more records but at this point I'm
trying to make a life for myself as a
producer and you know I was struggling
so the roots had a open mic
women in music series that they used to
do every Sunday at the wetlands okay in
New York every Sunday for a year I would
do this I was part of the house band was
me
Questlove you know a couple other cats
and I'm like crazy I mean all everybody
was their common was always there you
know Erykah Badu was there got me it was
a movie it went on every Sunday so
finally after a year of doing that they
did one in California at the martini
lounge okay so I see this girl when I go
out to the martini lounge my first time
ever in in California I never been to
Cali and this girl from Philly comes up
to me that I knew a rapper that I worked
with whatever and it was Eve trying to
Eve and Eve was like yo I got I got a
record deal with dr. Dre this is prior
to her going to reference before we like
really knew Eve yes she was like before
she wasn't like upstream to downstream
she was side streamed I guess you know
Dre was so busy with him and you know
yeah Dre had that weird era where he put
out that aftermath album with the bomb
on the cover and it was like more like a
compilation album yeah this was ever
after that yeah okay okay okay so yeah
we'd been there done that yeah yeah yeah
so so um I'm like out there like I'm
literally at this moment in my life
probably two months behind in my rent
and like struggling whatever and she's
like come me dr. Dre probably like 98 99
98 99
okay 19 is getting a 99 well yeah maybe
it wasn't 98 he was 90 a um at any rate
she says come me dr. Dre and you know
playing some music I was like I don't
have any music with me so we'll come
play the piano for him because I didn't
have any that tapes CDs and I played i
sat in the lobby and waited for a few
hours and you know he's like I hear you
hot on them Keith
so I played some [ __ ] he was like
he was like don't go anywhere got a
hotel room key and [ __ ] stack of
money like everything so I [ __ ] with us
we were making this album and he's just
like the vibe of like this different
like style I guess that he was used to
hearing in you know California musicians
that he would bring in different
keyboard players yeah yeah and it was
something completely different
East Coast but still like Universal
about it and he was [ __ ] with it so
he put me on the team Bros was honor I
learned everything there it's where I
learned to really understand music
production and how long was that era of
your career where you were in there
learning like woods right yeah like how
long did that last like four or five
years
so you're just soaking up like
everything like because he's so
meticulous I hear he's crazy about
Anders like you said you hated hearing
the gyro song in the club because you
could tell the difference yeah you
probably got that for being around Jess
a little short
um it's insane to think like I feel like
it's like still d-r-e like low-key like
the fact that you're a kid from Philly
and kind of shaped like West Coast
Sonics for like the next like eight or
nine years because if you go and like
listen to like Games documentary like I
just feel like those keys aren't there
west coast now like it's like you know
what I'm saying like there's records
that you hear that are like we kind of
you know I can't take credit for like
we'd raise productions obviously yeah
yeah like I brought to the table I
slowly like the chronic mm I brought a
certain it was more I mean was
production but it was like even more
like want to call it writing like we
were writing these things and this and
that and you know he was you know he
definitely had a vision for what he was
doing but I brought a new sound that was
different like then you know g-funk
exactly thing going on it was more
orchestral like pianos and you know
totally new did you because at the time
Dre had so many artists that I mean damn
I would have loved to have heard what a
rock
album what is someone like under
aftermath we were around for some of
that did you I was gonna ask you did you
work on the unreleased Rakim album yeah
how was that how did I you know that
rock him come meet me in Miami one time
work with me now is this like chemically
doesn't fly actually is this like peak
like storage like Miami time yeah but
yeah no but I mean we I worked with him
with Dre mm-hmm like right in LA and
then I worked with him later and there
has to be like legend talked about right
like that the rock in music that you
heard while he was under aftermath cuz
we never got to hear any of it I mean
someone's [ __ ] was pretty dope I can't
front
it was it was pure unadulterated him
he's just kind of rapper that like once
he opens his voice he's got a tone and a
particular style it grabs your attention
man DMX one of those people
oh yeah shout-out to the belly poster in
the room
legendary yeah no that's I always like
even like hit man there was I just felt
like there was so many fire artists in
there after method Devin the Dude did he
sign after me no I was just saying on
that album Devin's one of my favorites I
rap a lot rose so he definitely did fax
and you know I I miss it so much but I
used to all the time after you know
being in that crew be able to call my
brother Nate Dogg four hooks four songs
and you just you knew you was gonna get
a hit like goodnight goodnight you and
you and Nate's relationship very strong
Stimpy's yeah we were cool that's crazy
because I like what was the that he was
on it wasn't he on a kiss record it you
did we did yeah he was but there was a
record that I really liked dub C and him
the streets Def Jam
ya know heisman was the name of that a
yeah you know Deb see when I'm on my
favorite west coast rappers ever doesn't
get enough respect my favorite of the
three in West Side connection for the
record shot ice Cuban Mactan but yeah
man like and then obviously man like I
always tell this to shout out to Steve
Lobel
Steve LaBelle we working we work in the
election but I was in like yo man
whenever your Netflix mini documentary
series or movie or whatever your life
story fan is the wolf of Wall Street of
music dog yeah but like we gotta get
Steve LaBelle to play a cop in the movie
oh he's got a place gonna arrest me no
he's gotta play himself or I want to
know who plays Steve at the end of the
movie when when during your comeback of
the Bruce Willis oh my gag but now I'm
in Diesel you you you obviously it's
well documented by the way I thought it
was very corny the skits during that
battle that Manny fer I thought that was
the corniest [ __ ] ever but I digress
you can't dazzling with genius baffling
with [ __ ] shout-out to 6-9
nonetheless that era of your life I got
out of control right so there's a point
in time where you're clearly the biggest
producer I mean at your peak like what
was the Scott Storch beat costing was
like 80 rags that's crazy
was there ever an error in hip-hop where
people were getting like 250 a beat or
is that just how these situations me and
me and Tim Berlin we split a million
dollars for a beat
really yeah damn which beat was that huh
it was for a commercial a commercial
yeah for what company and one and one
shoes drop a million that's crazy yeah
you know he was commanding some crazy
money like I was just coming up he was
already there like chilling I was so I
was like goddamn but in that era I just
feel like you were one of those guys hmm
like you were like one of those guys
it's like if you get a Scott Storch be
like you're [ __ ] out of here yeah and
I was given everybody their money's
worth until now where's there ever any -
because I think there's always like
speculation that back then
certain female artists would sleep with
producers to get beats did that ever
happen no to get beat yeah we're like to
get a discount or like no I'm you know
they was playing 80,000 it was still
coming out of there it was still coming
under budget yeah that's crazy now but
like what do you remember the year that
[ __ ] started to kind of get a little
hazy and out of control like where it
was like [ __ ] man this is the this was
kind of the beginning of the end because
I originally you weren't a big club guy
right no I wasn't I was stuck in the
studio and then like somewhere just
after I turned 30 I think I went a
little cuckoo and I started getting into
you know the nightlife the paparazzi's
and this an excessive [ __ ] and then like
cocaine came into the play and and you
know Jack Daniels and lots of [ __ ] man
[ __ ] I can you could say whatever the
[ __ ] you want bling oh yeah lots of
[ __ ] and that was going crazy and I
stopped working the work just became
second and then so are we
what do we what do we call them this
like oh six oh seven we're calling this
oh seven leaning into oh eight more more
like oh that was kind of the beginning
of [ __ ] yeah
that's wild man and then yeah it's mean
you brought all these and all that Rosen
I just know that's a suit you have the
most legendary a hit list in hip hop if
it ever if it ever came out oh we didn't
have Instagram bro I'm hearing the
victims
chow you saw my fat Joe interview
reposted it yeah Fat Joe's like he
[ __ ] all of them all of them
if whoever you're thinking of in your
head right now
and my boy I remember my girl shut out
my guy DJ Chris John from Tampa for old
DJ but Chris John was like fam Scott
Storch his house he was coming down the
stairs when this [ __ ] on this and this
[ __ ] on the other and thumbs up the ass
thumbs up the ass of them and we're
talking about creme de la creme is what
we'll say yeah prior to them being that
we're in a new chapter
yeah and then you by the way
congratulations haven't you just had a
new baby yeah so come grab you know what
that past I'm like you know I feel like
I'm happy right now
because I did all that [ __ ] you got it
out of my system I'm like I'm cool I'm
content I'm not sweating no you know
going into club and trying to find [ __ ]
like I just did so much of that I got
I'm in the same I'm in the same same
vibe of my life I like waking up early
and hanging out with my bro watching
movie once you get that [ __ ] out of your
system the thing is you didn't starts
you were 30 so it you got you like got
it like you had to make up for your 20s
missing out on all know I was always a
[ __ ] monster in that department but
the women yeah was just like it was a
different thing it wasn't like how many
women have you had at the same time at
the most at once I can imagine some of
those parties had to end up with your
bedroom just being late as [ __ ] and you
and you be in this play for the movie
the movies are we talking like a
starting five like are we talking like a
five pack you know what I can say this
and I'd like to say this do that whole
era of me being with a lot you know
promiscuous or whatever I always treated
everybody with respect and we all
everybody always had a great time there
was never any funky [ __ ] going on in my
circle so no it was cool you know I
think his dope is your relationship with
Fat Joe because Fat Joe is one of those
guys who I feel like never wavered in
his friendship with you if that makes
sense
ya know he always remained loyal to
because I feel like a lot of people
Chris Brown as well I just feel like a
lot of people like
kind of wrote you off man and like I
think it's deservingly so but I think
looking out of my mind I mean fair
enough but I think a lot of times like
in our industry like once you can't do
something for somebody like you almost
like get the ignore on you know what I'm
saying like like did you a lot of those
people who maybe a lot of the people
that really cared for me wanted to
believe time and time again you know
they wanted to believe so they would you
know tolerate it with you know we you
know we just after a while you just
figure it out like it's a you know you
can't nobody can force you to to get
your act together you have to do it
together and then I want you to talk
about the project you have the heavenly
center which i think is a great approach
because I grew up around you know my
family being big big drug addicts and I
think the 12-step program is a little
dated hell yeah it's prehistoric it's
prehistoric and it's kind of like
faith-based you know it's kind of like
you know and I think that you know like
kind of from what I understand the
heavenly center is a cannabis centric
like a place to try to help people get
off certain drugs by by using cannabis
ground yeah not just I mean we allow the
cannabis and we'll educate you about the
cannabis and like try and evaluate you
and see what cannabis works the best for
you and how much of it is it's really
it's really helpful to get people off
opiate it's really individual yeah and
really helpful and for me it worked to
get off of cocaine and like you know I'm
living proof of that [ __ ] you know
people have anxiety mm-hmm when they
when they're recovering from hard
substances cannabis helps with that and
get you to that and people you start
enjoying the way feel and it's not like
a negative thing like where it's like
some of these drugs the the high that
comes from that destroys your life it's
not the case with cannabis so people
want to feel like they have something
that they can relax and you know just
and it's also uh it's an
anti-inflammatory so like I think a hard
like we talked
people get [ __ ] up on perks and shade
and heroin getting off the getting off
means those withdraws and if you could
just dab yourselves a collision yeah
sure you know it helps man
so the heavenly centers opening up win a
July 1st July 1st and it's in LA it's in
studio city studio city so it's in the
valley the heavenly I like that come on
man that's fire so is that something
that um like what like obviously we know
you're on the side comeback trail and we
know your lowest of your lows was what
was the inspiration of sanli you know
what I want to try to help people
yeah that was definitely part of it and
you know conversations with obviously
what Steve LaBelle and you know he's
always helping me you know guide me not
stealing trying to you know to uh expand
on one course and of course it's not
always about like making a beat like
there's so much more we can do like you
know dude you we wouldn't have we
wouldn't even have him rapping you would
still be just producing Thanks your your
your last five four or five years we
touched on that a little bit but we're
talking down below from rowdy Ridge
we're talking Russ what I mean
Trippi even like the stuff you did with
six nine you know crazy right like who
is the the one artist that is a
new-school artist that you feel like you
have an insane chemistry with like that
it's just like Russ for sure I was gonna
say it's gotta be not failed yet every
we've made I don't know we released how
many songs with him so far five five
more than that and Russ is the kind of
guy six or seven every time we would go
in a studio we worked six or set
whatever the number of Records that's
album is the number of records we did
and we all go out there that's why and
then like it's crazy because I I know
that like he kind of prides himself on
self production
but I remember seeing an interview was
like you know the one guy wanted to get
in with the Scott Storch yeah it was
saying I think dr. Dre me and Timbaland
where his top three like like getting
like letting like letting somebody like
into this creative process like it's got
an honor man it felt good like you know
when people like you know it gets you
inspired when you feel you know people
are feeling what you're doing and it's
like because they don't know what to
expect after you know when they're gonna
come into the studio with you like I
remember Russ was even saying he was
like man it's one thing to get an
opportunity to come in and work with
Scott Storch you know that but he's like
and then for it to be dope that's there
that's that that's the icing on the cake
100% man um your album is something that
I think is overdue because I think back
in the day when I overdue DJ Clue was
dropping the professional and like you I
mean timbrel and even you know I mean
obviously Tim was rapping Timlin imma go
oh my god shout to Magoo fake-ass q-tip
I love him though when I was a kid who's
one of my favorite rappers but I feel
like this is something is way overdue
man like are you reconnecting with any
of the veterans the vets Fat Joe's I
think I mean it's gonna be multifaceted
album and it's not just rap [ __ ] it's
gonna be all different kinds of [ __ ] on
there what about little country you know
some country but what like obviously you
when you don't say nothing I was I
remember as a kid seeing the article for
the ad in double XL and it's saying
produced by Scott Storch oh [ __ ] he's
back with doing a roots record no but I
I I'm wondering what would what would
have to happen like now like what would
that be something where you'd be like
you I need a like it's my debut album I
need to bring thought in question to do
a record like we're going down it's
already half talk to black thought maybe
a month ago about it by the way black
thoughts are one of the greatest rappers
of like I want to make a record like
with Black Thought and like Jay Cole
something crazy request low on the drums
right [ __ ] like that
that sounds like a hip-hop wet dream
yeah I told them already I told both of
them that's all J Cole and I told Dan
hasn't called that's great yo you
working with six nine obviously prior to
all this crazy [ __ ] going on I remember
seeing that video you won the keys
it was the Tauri record yeah by the way
Tory sure that that that hook was crazy
right crazy he killed it was there a but
was there any other records that that we
didn't we never heard that you guys did
yeah do you always like is there is that
like vaca no no I mean are there any
records there that we have that haven't
come out that are too long what is that
like I wonder as a producer because on
the hip-hop side of things I feel like a
lot of rappers just saw I mean he's kind
of blackballing them so but as a
producer you're kind of not necessarily
I don't know if you're held to the same
standards like would you would you work
with someone like him again if it made
sense I've you know I hate I don't even
want to answer this question because I
know people are gonna intentionally for
what no matter what I say if I said I
would I will warn whatever they're gonna
like you know just talk about it but
I'll just say this you know I don't turn
my back on anybody in life I mean you've
been you've been in some low places man
I've been in some little places you know
that's hey that's some real [ __ ] man
that's some real [ __ ] yo is there ever a
beat of yours that you wish like that
came out that like maybe it was a record
that you were like you know what it
wasn't worth the bag
yeah those have happened let's not even
address those can we have any examples
at all just one gonna give us one there
had to be a record that dropped that
you're like damn like maybe it's
somebody who's not around anymore
not I mean obviously maybe they're just
you know I can act I don't wanna you
know I can't I don't want to offend
yeah there's been some registering way
let me go through you know what more
than there were being records that were
wack
there's records that sometimes I
remember jay-z telling me that record
went to the wrong person
he sat me that he was like you should
well give us that example you don't
remember you know that's real because a
lot of it is uh
it's fit right it's like Dan can you
imagine if I always remember I don't
know if you watched the the jay-z
documentary where Tim Allen's plane and
beads and he and sindorim plays him to
post you know that's that balance and
then Luda ended up with the potion and
jay-z passed on it yeah and it was like
oh it happens all the time Shane what I
got on that [ __ ] or you know like you
maybe you had one artist who's here and
then there's another artist that's your
favorite artist then it's a huge artist
and the one artist came to see you and
you were playing beats and then they
ended up getting that you're like you
didn't realize that next week you were
meeting with this [ __ ] massive artist
and you're like [ __ ]
but you God you can't I'm not grinding
me like that I don't I know a lot of
stories where people will take the [ __ ]
they're like yeah no no I need that be
back like jay-z
oh yeah this one already took it
whatever I've never done that okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna take a guess let me get
a guess on on a wack beat or a beat a
song of yours that you weren't a fan of
let me just get a guess let's go with
Brooke Hogan's about us come on man I
see what his interview is going
shoutout to Brooke Hogan man yo yeah I
mean we're kind of being filmed right
now so go ahead
Big Bang Big Bang now was the Brooke
Hogan with that was that was that was
that Hall Cogan money huh or was that
from her label that was from her label
that's crazy that was did you like chop
it up did you chop it up with Hulk
that's crazy
gangster the Hulkster I'm sorry you know
it's it's interesting cuz like yo you
did shutterbug
shut up that was such a great [ __ ]
hell man oh you know what's interesting
about that song that's the only record
that I'm proud of at all that I made as
a complete [ __ ] junkie cuz it was in
that era right yes that's interesting
yeah I'm looking I'm looking at the
records during that time and I'm like I
know that's the one that's the
conversation
I remember big boy he was like man
people warned me they were like son when
he was in the studio I was [ __ ]
sweating profusely
going to the bathroom to [ __ ] do coke
and [ __ ] like [ __ ] up with that record
thing I was right now I don't know how
outside of the million dollar commercial
do you remember the beat that you got
paid the most for by a label broken no
no no no I mean outside of that because
that was a commercial so like but I'm
saying that do you remember like yo the
most I mean you got in your heavy like
yo I remember the biggest bag I got for
a beat in my tea
like what do you remember what record
that was no I mean those bags are cool
the big bags come when they
[ __ ] go right cuz when the
record goes that's when the real bag
it's crazy cuz like I wouldn't when you
did the bat I was like Africa like you
like launch Chris Brown bro like you had
his first single like that nobody knows
that artists are gonna be where they end
up going right in Chris Brown at that
time it was 16 years old he was just
turning 16 just turned in 16 years old
and you're the one of the biggest
producers in the world at the time like
what did you see that in him like
earlier was it just like for you just
like another placement my kid
nah man like I made him a promise the
day I met him I was like you know I'm
making you a number one
right now and like I just had a feeling
like he just seemed like for its time
the new Michael Jackson like kids
dancing cuz had a crazy ass voice that
age and I could tell his whole
personality soul style and everything go
and especially since the people that
brought in there one of them was Mark
Pitts
you know discovered you and Dre's
relationship how is it today
great how's he like like like I sent him
my single you like to nice I had to get
approval from the Godfather
did you like it like acknowledged like
yo man on my prouder you Scott I feel
like we all should be like shows Mad
Love a fans a hip-hop like man like your
comebacks to his crazy bro and it's just
getting started you know I'm but I'm
glad that I'm evolving into a guy that
is making his own records and not just
being like a you know a beat [ __ ] I'm
making my own albums and my own records
movies when you say a beat [ __ ] that
what do you what are you saying
like somebody who just sells beats to
everybody in
that's no it's cool but when you making
big records like and you're taking the
time to put into work and be a dj khaled
and go sue Uli's [ __ ] hell trying to
get clearances and getting vocals and do
vocals in the vocals yeah - it isn't
listen I'm one record deep and I'm like
damn no respect to Khalid because
happiness to deal with everyone's teams
I mean that's it's it's low-key like
it's a lot because I put out a project
before and it was like it was a lot man
it's a lot to have you been coming from
your background and being as musical as
you are but like you said you kind of
had to relearn where music is now and
I've seen you in the studio even if
stuff doesn't end up dropping I've seen
you in the studio so many of these young
kids from this young generation and I
feel like
sometimes I'll see you in the studio sir
Nara black man that I don't know that
kid deserves to be in the studio with
Scott Storch just cuz like artistically
I think a lot of there's a lot of a lot
of the [ __ ] that's coming out in the
last couple years it's kind of been
whatever yeah I mean I have to
experiment sometimes I have to like take
a closer look at the artist and see if
it can work and not sometimes is there
ever a time where you're like man I just
I just can't do this like this is just
not yes
that's happened with the new guys yeah
100%
who's like somebody right I'm gonna tell
you one of the things that's crazy to me
yeah like there's uh you know people
rapping you know I'm not stylistically
but on be okay some really a lot of
people like it and I've grown accustomed
to rap completely offbeat I like it
slightly offbeat when it's completely
not even remotely anywhere new ladies
and gentlemen things have gone blue face
like you know what it might not come
back who are some of the producers that
inspire you now there's a whole wave of
young guys that are - is fire doesn't
get finals don't have like it yeah hip
boys incredible like I also feel like -
like with where music is - like the EDM
[ __ ] is kind of its own thing you know
like is that something that like you can
see yourself like doing a EDM record on
your album or working with someone like
marshmallow to order yeah
EDM is an EDM anymore it's definitely
just pop music like you listen to the
chainsmokers you're like this is 100 bpm
got rowdy rich on a single they're
making a rap [ __ ] it is craziest house
party you've ever through
crazy was back in like 1967 mom's game
what about waking up the next day what's
the biggest thing you would like what
like I always feel like we all have
those nights where it's like damn did
this [ __ ] even happen like I don't like
bro I don't even remember how I would
get there sometimes but I would wake up
in the middle of the ocean on my not
knowing how you got there and 10-piece
yeah just all ass naked all not even in
the bedrooms mad bedrooms in the boat
but like on top of the boat like out in
the front like just [ __ ] like drink
spilled everywhere just not even
remember on a boat that [ __ ] is crazy
and then you had a interesting era where
you you and you and little campbell kind
of a thing you guys were like cool i
feel like you guys were like one of the
early hiphop power/power
situations that were ruined it was a
very brief moment but our friendship was
very like we didn't really like we
weren't together like that we were cool
but we more like enjoyed each other's
company as like more of a brotherly
sisterly thing because we you it wasn't
really a physical connection like a
friendship
were you which which album did you
because she had a she had that to to
album run in that era where was like
notorious key I am and then the Bella
mafia was ladders up right it was that
that was a great album I remember when
you played that [ __ ] in that battle I
was like man I forgot what song do you
wish you would have played during the
battle that he's like
maybe a couple of choices that I had
influenced around me that was like is
there one that you left out there like
[ __ ] this one it was like kind of the
obvious one that could have got played
the album hopefully will be getting soon
you say you got five or six records yeah
that you feel good about their album
quality that these are going they might
need to be touched up yeah whoo can you
tell us who else is for sure making the
album no okay have you know it's funny
cuz I remember one art one one one are
so I want to hear you with all right I
got to actually introduce you to was the
baby did you guys ever end up getting
together and creating after that I think
was during the Grammys right it was like
Grammy week broke I don't know how but I
somehow spaced ever sending him a pack
and I want to work with him again I'm
gonna me and like I would just be
collecting joints and I was always
waiting for one more to come that was
better to send yeah like when you it's
crazy that you're like yo like Stewart
just sending out packs
you don't see I'm like I don't do that
for anybody I bet ya but an artist like
him I like you know a huge fan most
people that I'll send the pack - yeah
like two of the illest guys right now me
who else do you like as a fan lyrically
coming from a guy who started out with
[ __ ] one of the greatest rappers of
all time as the vocalist of your group
Shia Black Thought who like lyrically
right now do you respect like I'm some
bar shaped like of course have you have
you got to work with him yet listen we
got to get the Benny the butcher the
Westside shout out to Conway shout out
to that whole
you know an album that you should check
out I think it appreciate is Madlib and
Freddie Gibbs put an album out last year
that was amazing
like did you ever cuz coming up in that
era like when you were hot like there
was this other world where it was like
mad lib and black milk and all these
like super grimy ass rap producers did
you like ever like tap in with any of
that type of [ __ ] or were you just kind
of in your own world because you kind of
came from that world too low yeah
what about J Dilla did you ever link
like did you and him ever have any time
where you guys cross paths
nobody influenced record reaching for
that style when he was no Mars two demos
where's the where is your first Grammy
right now yeah the roots Grammy where's
that at do you still really we got the
certificate damn that [ __ ] is crazy
that's disappointing man I want it I
want anybody who's watching this man
like who's been through some addiction
or might be going through some addiction
right now obviously besides pulling up
to the heavenly center June 1st through
July 1st July 1st July 1st I'm coming
man I mean yeah listen trust for the
soul I've been through a lot of drug
addiction [ __ ] in my life not personally
around my family yeah but what is um I
always would always like what I've
learned from experiencing it is like you
can't it's frustrating dealing with
somebody who is addicted to some [ __ ]
because you you just want them to listen
to you and to just get clean but like
it's really I know it's so cliche but I
feel like I mean you could tell me if
I'm wrong it's like you know it's it's
it's up to you like when you're ready
after one you have to want to get clean
you can't
get caught getting high in the bathroom
and now are you ready like it does not
to be a person who's like oh yeah I'm
ready to get clean right now they just
all you have to do is want to do you
think people have to hit rock bottom
first yeah I mean some people might get
a scare what was what was your rock
bottom do you remember that moment where
it was like man this is I remember cuz I
remember times when I lived in Vegas and
Molly Moll would be like yo Scott Storch
a staying at my crib right now like you
know I'm saying like this was when I
went for 2010-2011 back in the day but
like do you remember your moment when it
was like the last time you know what I'm
saying I can imagine your wife marijuana
yeah shout out to Steve Lobel but first
and foremost I was ready to give it up
I knew it was either for me you never
did you never do like it locked up
during that whole [ __ ] or was there tons
or you did did some overnight [ __ ] in
jail I got arrested one time I got
arrested one time in Vegas it had to be
great and it'd be a great terrible night
and I got caught hotel room with cocaine
like not a lot like like crumbs
that's some wild [ __ ] to get arrested
for in Vegas yeah it's like what do you
think people like we're in Vegas
[ __ ] like what do you think I'm
doing in my hotel room and then any
advice you would give to uh you know I
manage a couple producers and I feel
like the production coming up as a
producer nowadays I feel like is it
probably was always harder but I just
feel like with the technology that's
available it's much easier to get into
producing I'm not saying it's easier to
get good at it but same way with DJ I'm
like back in the day you used to have to
buy turntables and records and it was a
lot now you just get a little [ __ ]
toy and your app like but for producers
who you know like want to try to break
through like what is some advice you
would give to them because I feel like
there it's it's it's a lot of it is
lovely producer yeah it for a producer
someone who's fine an artist to produce
and get them a record deal hey yeah I
mean look at the babies do justice bank
worth fifty a hundred [ __ ] that's
crazy
are you currently grooming any artists
under you under under Scott's tortures
futures hold it totally different yeah I
think you know the music I want to hear
shout out to my guy be I heard you got
you and doobie did a little a little I
don't know he pee or something you shout
out to do be man go ahead we got
cigarettes I do in my bag this guy's got
this guy Casey is the cigarette god oh
this guy's a walking [ __ ] cigarette
that's all he [ __ ] does the smoke god
bless him I love him
we - yeah you'll see at the end of this
we're gonna do you'll see at the end of
this we're gonna do a two minute radio
joint
it'll be like mr. Weaver mr. Weaver uh
ma'am
all right we good this is light up that
goddamn that cigarette butt but let's
get to it
yo you and our Kelly working together
what was that session like that session
was another one of those situations
where record didn't go we were supposed
to go should have went to someone else
no watch this I forget the name of the
goddamn group but do you remember I
never signed to be to some group for
something like like do you remember who
they were saying to so I could find out
this information I'm gonna talk to my ex
manager back in a day my boy Derek but I
I sold him the beat and they wanted to
get our Kelly features and they got our
Kelly featured and our Kelly said hold
up I want this I want this and I don't
you guys are not getting paid to get off
a man that's crazy
so you weren't even in the session with
Kells no it was something that like
people who bought them at the shore club
in Miami one
from like New Year's like it was then he
was saying is that I'm not talking about
I'm on a social level at all on a social
level on a musical level he's a genius
one of the greatest artists ever are
Kelly and Usher
nobody standoff destroy that no he'd
destroy everyone
III agree 100% unfortunately like you
said it's like I think that at the end
of the day you're allowed well you know
you're allowed to I think you're allowed
to separate art from the person man if
that makes sense
you know like [ __ ] I love art Kelly as
music I don't love him I mean I don't
know that [ __ ] but his music was
just like yeah right 12 play like fools
I like your hair stand up like man a
hundred percent bro yo you work in a you
working with 50 cent on the massacre
massacre I always feel like doesn't get
it just do for how [ __ ] incredible
that album was I think that get Richard
that train had such high you know
expectations it was almost impossible to
follow it up but but talk about like you
will fit these chemistry because there
was some chemistry there I mean you guys
made some classic music and that was the
comfort zone I'm gonna tell you one of
the first reasons why is you know Dre
had me in his studio and he seen me in
dre studio so there was a comfort zone
like you know there's a certain quality
and a bar set by dre and I wouldn't be
in there if I wasn't supposed to be in
there so he had he was comfortable with
me in my opinion
music and what I was he knew you
wouldn't be there if yeah so he knew my
like my vision is cool you know people
always second-guess especially in that
time because it's not like now where
everything I mean I'm not trying to
[ __ ] [ __ ] on [ __ ] but there's a lot
of [ __ ] that sounds like a lot we were
making every song was its own thing
are you are artistically frustrated when
you hear some of this [ __ ] [ __ ] lock
into the trap bubble and [ __ ] the new
drum sounds in this bad boy
bro I was [ __ ] putting up kicks like
crazy [ __ ] like if you're listening like
the Leanback drum where were you getting
your drums from because I always did you
because I remember Kanye said that he he
would steal drums from a lot of dr. Dre
[ __ ] listen we would so would you would
you ever take any drums from Dreier did
he ever give you anything
I got drums from Timberman I got are
those drums you still lose it using this
day no no [ __ ] disco all that
[ __ ] I was going I could get it again
but you know sure certain ones are still
very essential but you know the Sonics a
chance did you work on any iteration of
detox at all
I was that kind of the era in which you
and Ray weren't close anymore
we had because I know there's like a
million iterations there's help vaults
you know I don't think he ever was
working specifically on like he would
make music and it's something really he
gravitated towards it then I'm sure he
probably would have wanted to keep it
for that and for whatever but you know
why do you think you and jay-z never had
a real moment if that makes sense the
way Jay had his moments with pre
and had his moments with Timberland like
why do you think jay-z and that Scott
Stewart rain never I feel like there was
was that is that like a thing like cuz
if you think of like who do we think of
hope like when we think of hope if we
think of Primo Timbaland then later on
Just Blaze Kanye Lake so that was a
Swiss oh my god him and Swiss yeah he
was on the Rough Riders I'm but like
back then that that was a thing like it
definitely happened with The Neptunes I
feel like it's something like with a lot
of artists you would be like Neptune's
are always gonna be on a cert solo album
but like who did you have that with
anybody did amen
let me tell you something I don't
remember something ever being bigger and
lean back when I was a kid during that
summer that shoot was I heard it was
going crazy I wasn't there at summer jam
in New York
yo that and that be like yo man what
like I think that if you just take away
the lyrics that's one thing to about
these beat battles that's frustrating
cuz I'm like yo man who can really just
play beats and be like oh [ __ ] that's
one of them beats stand up oh my god
what do you think is your hardest beat
like what's your beat they're like
that's
that was his first single on Alpha
Restless right very amazing I'm shot of
the exhibit look Scott me you're a
[ __ ] legend hopefully we'll get the
album before 2021
are you gonna be doing I know for a
while there I would see you like I want
to play in the keys live it places a
[ __ ] you know what I feel like you could
have a Vegas residency definitely
especially after going through you know
socially distance and just at the house
so much I'm kind of inspired to go and
you know hit the road yeah when I hit
the road but do some specific dates and
some specific placement oh sure
I saw like when you came out with Russ
that [ __ ] was amazing you know support
the record and yeah man listen I
remember what what show did you come out
with Russell was out here Staples Center
yeah that [ __ ] is crazy that was the
vibe man shout out to Russ I'm sure you
guys I'm sure you guys know more music
coming out which record the 3 a.m.
that's you fire a shout-out to Abaddon -
we should not have it done have a dawn
is a wonderful man from the Netherlands
is that a man shout shout to the
Netherlands and shout out to you may
appreciate you for coming through I
can't wait to hear the [ __ ] album